bonsoir le point sur l'actualité locale
du lundi au vendredi sur tv fil 78 avec
le journal de la rédaction voici les
principaux titres de ce jeudi 7 mai 2015
une nouvelle étude vient confirmer
l'insalubrité du centre nautique de
maurepas la municipalité entérine donc
la fermeture se pose maintenant la
question à des travaux ou de la
destruction le préfet des yvelines vient
de remettre les insignes de la légion
d'honneur à des anciens combattants ce
matin veille de la célébration de la
victoire des alliés sur l'allemagne
nazie et puis l'église catholique des
yvelines se penche sur l'affectivité et
la sexualité des jeunes des assises
diocésaine vont se tenir ce week end
pour en parler le père matthew dupont
à la réforme du collège porté par un âge
as tu vas l'eau à belkacem de plus en
plus contesté à droite comme à gauche et
c'est le président de la république qui
vient au secours de sa ministre de
l'éducation françois hollande était est
aux mureaux cet après midi pour apporter
son soutien aux propositions émises il
l'a une nouvelle fois être dénoncé un
concert d ea mobile souhaitant défendre
des intérêts particuliers ce déplacement
de dernière minute précède un discours
prononcé en cette fin de journée de
l'umih la maison de la chimie à paris le
président doit défendre des mesures
proposées dans cette réforme
5 à 6000 suppressions de postes dans le
monde dont quatre à cinq mille en france
l'annoncé d'un plan social par areva ce
jeudi n'a pas surpris grand monde et les
pertes records enregistrés par le géant
du nucléaire ces dernières années 4 8
milliards uniquement en 2014 nécessite
une baisse des effectifs et cela
concernera le site de montigny le
bretonneux où travaille un millier de
salariés restent à déterminer à quel
degré la négociation avec les syndicats
pour structurer le dialogue social et la
gestion des emplois et des compétences
est en cours annonce la direction areva
prévoit également un milliard d'euros
d'économies sur les trois prochaines
années
le troisième et dernière audit du centre
nautique de maurepas a confirmé l les
craintes plusieurs éléments métalliques
subissent une corrosion avancée menaçant
la stabilité des assemblages la
municipalité a donc annoncé la fermeture
du site mikael hed
le centre nautique de maurepas prend
l'eau la structure fermée depuis le 7
avril le restera jusqu'à nouvel ordre un
troisième audit a confirmé que plusieurs
éléments de la piscine subissent une
corrosion avancée conséquence la
stabilité de la piscine est menacée nous
avons les faux plafonds qui menace de
s'effondrer et donc qui menacent la
sécurité du public qui menacent la
sécurité du public et d'autres éléments
structuraux également qu'ils sont et qui
risque la rupture est donc je prends
toutes les mesures qui s'imposent pour
protéger le public je ferme donc jusqu'à
nouvel ordre la piscine de maurepas
cette fermeture fait beaucoup de vagues
dans la commune une pétition baptisée
maurepas sans piscine c'est non a été
lancée par l'opposition municipale pour
sauvegarder le centre nautique entre
nous
je vous disais tout à l'heure des
habitants sont vraiment attachés
donc aujourd'hui nous on continue la
mobilisation
plus nous aurons à nous mobiliser
sur le mannequin son public à bord nous
aurons à 4 accupé de l'arrivée on peut
qu'appuyer sur quelques
battra pas les bras une réunion sur ce
thème sera organisée ce samedi à 11
heures au café le mord pas l'opposition
municipale apportera des informations
sur les différents audits réalisés sur
le centre nautique une pétition et des
critiques injustifiées selon le maire de
la commune tout le monde comprend et
tout le monde savait d'ailleurs l'état
de cette structure
d'ailleurs je me pose des questions
pourquoi les travaux n'ont pas été
réalisés en 2007 ou 2008 puisque les
700000 euros qui était déjà prévue par
l'audit de 2009 non ont été refusées par
l'ancienne équipe je me pose des
questions pourquoi s'ils savaient pas
été refusée si ça avait été engagée on
n'en serait pas arrivé là on aurait pu
penser d'autres solutions alternatives
mais évidemment il n'y a qu'à
responsable et c'est le maire de mort
par deux pistes sont désormais à l'étude
par la mairie une réhabilitation de la
structure ou la construction d'une
nouvelle piscine en janvier prochain
maurepas intégrera la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le maire ump
mettra le dossier sur la table alors
pour le moment nous n'en avons pas parlé
ensemble c'est une priorité pour les
villes de maurepas d'elancourt et de
coignières donc nous allons mettre ce
dossier ce dossier sur la table et
évidemment je pense que ça fera partie
des négociations mais en tout cas il
faut que la piste ne porte pas de
maurepas soit une priorité pour la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin à mon avis il n'y aura pas de
financement total deux du nouveau centre
aquatique de maurepas mais il y aura des
aides comment on fait pour chaque
commune a pris à chaque commune de
savoir bien utiliser les aides
financières qui viendraient de la
communauté d'agglomération un dossier
important 170 mille personnes dont 48
scolaire fréquenté la structure tous les
ans
politique première conférence de presse
depuis son entrée en campagne pour
valérie pécresse candidate ump aux
régionales en ile-de-france l'occasion
pour elle de présenter les dix porte
parole qu'ils accompagneront pendant
cette campagne mais également de
fustiger l'action du parti socialiste à
la tête de la région ile de france
depuis 17 ans à son président notamment
jean paul huchon la députée des yvelines
de monde des contes la campagne a certes
débuté tôt pour elle mais c'est pour
faire réagir ses adversaires à politique
explique-t-elle on les gouttes je
propose que ce mois de mai soit consacré
à ce qu'on prenne bien conscience que en
dix sept ans les comptes qu'ils ont à
rendre aux franciliens sont mauvais il à
vous prenez la vente sur le ps je les
oblige surtout à a essayé de
le bilan de la façon dont ils ont géré
11 milliards et demi d'euros d'argent
public
rip 13 qui répondait aux questions de
nos confrères de votv lors de cette
conférence de presse elle qui occupe
donc également le poste de député des
yvelines a désigné je vous le disais
c'est dit porte-parole locaux et parmi
eux othman un assaut conseiller
municipal la d'opposition à trappes en
charge de promo pole pour la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
à 27 ans il est chargé de relayer les
informations concernant la campagne dans
notre département et puis les régionales
toujours mais à gauche cette fois-ci fin
du suspense le député ps benoît hamon ne
sera pas candidat à la primaire en ile
de france face au président sortant jean
paul huchon est à sa première adjointe
marie pierre de la gontrie cette
dernière a d'ailleurs annoncé qu'elle se
ralliait finalement à claude bartolone
le président de l'assemblée nationale
qui lui a décidé de se présenter une
nouvelle donne qui poussent maintenant
jean paul huchon à la réflexion va-t-il
abandonner se retirer l'heure est à la
négociation alors que son camp est donné
pour l'instant battu par les sondages
l'ump l'emporterait en décembre ce midi
à la fondation banque populaire val de
france à a permis une donation à la
fondation université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines à hauteur de 25
mille euros l'engagement de
l'établissement bancaire va s'étaler sur
trois ans le total sera portée à 75000
euros un montant qui va aider au
déploiement du cluster de compétences
vert et bleu et notamment une version
mobile elle ce site est destiné à mettre
en relation les étudiants les
enseignants chercheurs les diplômes et
les entreprises et qu'ils peuvent poster
des offres d'emploi à ce jour 4500
profils ont été créés plus de 1000
recruteurs sont inscrits un partenariat
qui a mis plus d'un an à être signé on
est vraiment à l'université du
territoire où les politiques et les
parents les industriels de font
confiance donne de l'argent
c'est une grande famille c'est une
reconnaissance pour universités pour ses
activités de formation de recherche nous
a pas échappé que côté que c'est un peu
compliqué non seulement dans les
finances publiques également dans le
privé et il a beaucoup de sollicitations
beaucoup de sollicitations non il faut
arriver jusqu'à la personne qui a la
possibilité de donner l'argent dans une
entreprise il faut arriver à ces eaux
faut arriver à solliciter la personne à
avoir un rendez-vous la convaincre que
c'est intéressant d'avoir un partenariat
ça prend beaucoup de temps encore et
puisque nous parlons de l'université
vous les avez peut-être vu hier devant
la gare de 50 ans les étudiants en iut
de l'iut de rambouillet qui sont
inscrits en formation technique de
commercialisation
une partie d'entre eux en tout cas
organisé un flashmob pour promouvoir une
association bougeons-nous c'est son nom
l oeuvre notamment pour redonner une
dignité aux personnes âgées sans
ressources l'organisation de cet
événement s'inscrivait dans le cadre de
leur projet d'études comme nous
l'expliquent mathilde gamme baird
bouger c'est le mot d'ordre du jour pour
ces étudiants et l'association bougeons
nous les élèves de l'université de
rambouillet ont organisé un flashmob
dans la diagonale de la gare de montigny
le bretonneux le but faire connaître
l'association dans le cadre de notre
formation doit faire un projecteur et
avec une association pour l'aider à se
reconnaître donc du coup on a eu l'idée
de faire un flash mob donc c'est une
chorégraphie qui va faire en plein
milieu donc yasser en plein milieu de la
place et ses rangs pour enfin c'est
bonjour nous donc c'est avec l'esprit de
la danse et vont être jugés pour
association une opération bénéfique pour
cette jeune association créée en 2013
entre trois amis originaires de la
république du congo elle compte
désormais 15 monde qu'elle a pour but
d'aider les enfants les plus démunis de
la rdc donc nous soutenons
un groupe d'enfants orphelins et ainsi
que des jeunes filles qui sont victimes
de maltraitance donc financièrement
moralement tout ce qu'on peut faire bas
c'est toujours un plus c'est toujours du
bonus donc on a besoin vraiment l'aide
du soutien de tout le monde pour voilà
pour bouger et notre slogan c'est
ensemble nous allons bouger basé à
elancourt l'association a pour projet la
réhabilitation du centre de santé ou
encore la construction d'une école à
kinshasa
le journal qui se poursuit avec l'église
catholique qui se saisit d'un sujet
délicat des assises sont annoncés à
partir de demain jusqu'à vendredi à
versailles sur le thème affectivité
sexualité des jeunes les 10-18 ans
l'invité de ce jeudi le père matthieu
dupont pour soir vous êtes supérieur du
séminaire diocésain de l'église
catholique donc département vous faites
partie des organisateurs de ce
rendez-vous aujourd'hui l'église sous
l'impulsion ont sans doute aussi du pape
françois ne se refuse aucun sujet je
vais tout de même préciser qu'en début
de semaine justement le pape avait déjà
invité protestants et catholiques à
dialoguer sur la sexualité à dépasser
l'idée des catholiques rétrograde et des
protestants laxistes oui il ya de fait
ce sujet en fait nous touche tous vous
et moi avant d'être catholiques
protestants nous sommes hommes et femmes
et il ya en fait un peu plus de trois
ans notre évêque monseigneur aumônier
l'évêque du diocèse de versailles donc
le département des yvelines avait
consulté l'ensemble des chrétiens
catholiques des yvelines et dans cette
consultation qu'on appelle un synode
dans dans l'église et bien était avait
surgi ce sujet de l'éducation affective
et sexuelle notamment des jeunes des 10
18 ans et donc c'est fort de cela que
notre évêque a créé une commission dont
j'ai fait partie et cette commission est
comme premier objectif c'est d'abord de
se confronter à la réalité de quoi
parlons nous au delà de nos idéologies
au delà parfois des prêts compréhension
que nous avons et donc nous sommes allés
à la rencontre de professionnels
croyants ou non qui ont pu nous faire
remonter les paroles des jeunes de quoi
parle-t-il et c'est à partir de là et
bien que nous avons commencé à réfléchir
et à monter ces assises telles qu'elles
vont se vivre donc demain et
après-demain à versailles également pour
l'église catholique si je vous dis que
la sexualité le plaisir sexuel sont
liées au mariage reste forcément lié
aussi la procréation parce que c'est une
image dépassé c'est une image j'allais
dire partiel bien sûr ces trois mots
vous avez évoqué mariage plaisir
procréation sont appelés à être compris
dans un ensemble aujourd'hui on peut
aller un peu trop vite dans des flots
goran qu'on a pu entendre l'église et
contre le plaisir tout réside uniquement
dans le mariage non il ya comme un
cheminement que nous avons tous affaire
qui commence de la petite enfance
passant par l'adolescence bien cher
jusqu'à l'âge adulte et c'est dans ce
cheminement là et bien que nous voulons
permettre à chacun j'allais dire d'
humaniser la sexualité
tout n'est pas donné tout au début nous
apprenant à marcher nous apprenons à
lire nous apprenons à aimer et bien
quelque part y compris cette dimension
de notre vie nous avons à apprendre à
découvrir peu à peu et bien comment la
vivent pleinement et librement et je
crois que c'est d'abord cela l'enjeu des
assises que nous allons vivre et puis
aussi c'est ce message que nous avons à
découvrir comment articuler par exemple
plaisir et sentiments comment articuler
plaisir et confiance comment acculé
plaisir et durer voilà deux mots qu'on
associe et bien justement l'église
catholique veut pouvoir permettre à
chacun si j'ose dire de pouvoir vivre
pleinement sa sexualité c'est de lever
les tabous qu'il n'y ait pas de tabou
alors allons jusqu'au bout de justement
de cette question l'église catholique
aujourd'hui ne rejette pas la sexualité
en mariage la contraception par des
méthodes artificiel où les rapports
homosexuels par exemple l'église
aujourd'hui veut accueillir la sexualité
telle qu'elle se présente à nous est
telle que nous contemporain les vivent
elle veut l'accueillir comme je
l'évoquais de façon réelle mais aussi en
réfléchissant de quoi parlons nous ne
sommes pas qu'un corps nous sommes
certains corps est aujourd'hui par
exemple à la suite de des discours ou
des catéchèses des enseignements qu a pu
donner le pape jean paul ii nous avons
certainement re découvert dans l'église
la place du corps qu'est ce que nous dit
le corps le corps n'est pas une simple
enveloppe n'est pas un simple objet que
je peux utiliser le corps me dit quelque
chose et comment je vais essayer dans
toute ma vie et bien d'intégrer sedin a
mis ses pulsions ses désirs son bon et
comment je vais avec mon intelligence
avec ce que je suis et bien permettre
d'unifier je vais dire mon amour cette
humanité que chacun d'entre nous porte
ce week-end 350 éducateurs par
enseignant prêtres les catéchistes
responsables de mouvements de jeunesse
qui vont se retrouver appelez vous
l'avez dit par monseigneur eric aumônier
évêque de versailles ce sera au lycée
agence injuste à versailles ce sont les
différentes questions on imagine qu'ils
seront qui seront abordés ce que je vous
posais tout à l'heure mais finalement
c'est quel est le but c'est d'apporter
des réponses aux adultes pour qu'ensuite
ils puissent communiquer aux jeunes vous
avez vous adressé directement à ces
jeunes le but comme vous l'avez évoqué
c'est d'abord devenir des éducateurs des
éducateurs qui viennent de partout des
établissements d'enseignement catholique
mais aussi de ceux qui sont dans les
aumôneries de l'enseignement public de
différents mouvements je pense au
scoutisme je pense aussi à des
professeurs ou des professionnels qui
vont se rassembler ensemble non pas pour
entendre une vérité qu'il faudrait
plaqués et pour accueillir la parole des
uns et des autres pour faire surgir une
proposition l'idée est pas uniquement de
se rassembler pour brasser des belles
idées l'idée de pouvoir entre éducateurs
accueillir la réalité réfléchir recevoir
l'éclairage c'est vrai de l'église mais
aussi entrer dans une dynamique
éducative comment ce que nous allons
vivre ensemble à pouvoir se concrétiser
dans des projets locaux et donc à la fin
des assises seront lancés une vingtaine
de projets locaux se rassemblant les
éducateurs selon en fait les régions de
des yvelines où ils oeuvrent à des
projets concrets c'était la volonté
et comme au niveau tout à fait l'idée
vraiment d'accueillir la réalité pour
pouvoir ensuite concrètement au plus
près c'est à dire que ça ne part pas
d'en haut pour redescendre mais que
chacun là où il est chaque acteur puisse
ensemble est bien vrai à une proposition
qui verrait plutôt peut-être les
sixièmes qui vers les lycéens qui faire
d'autres types de deux populations j'ai
de jeunes comment ça reste drôle il y
aura différents ateliers thématiques
alors ces assises donc se déploie sur
deux jours l'idée est d'avoir quatre
portes d'entrée comme nous avons appelé
une première qui sera commune à tous
accueillir la réalité quesque de quoi
parlons nous quelles sont les attentes
des jeunes la deuxième plus
philosophique s'interroger bien qu'est
ce que l'on peut dire de l'homme
aujourd'hui notre société pas il ya deux
mille ans mais aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
l'homme et une troisième qui sera plus
théologique elle en n'ayant pas peur
théologique c'est quel regard de
l'église sur l'homme cette église qui
est au service des plus pauvres cette
église qui est attentif et une
encyclique de notre part françois arrive
sur l'écologie et bien cette église est
aussi une parole simple et belle sur la
sexualité et enfin troisième quatrième
porte d'entrée et bien l'aspect éducatif
donc les participants vont passer dans
ses quatre portes pour pouvoir réfléchir
ensemble et ensuite le samedi en début
d'après-midi et bien se retrouver pour
se dire qu avons nous reçu qu'allons
nous faire il ya des inquiétudes
aujourd'hui de la part des adultes au
delà même de l'église sur ces questions
de sexualité qui touche les plus jeunes
avec internet par exemple et u11 sondage
qui a été dévoilée par le parisien
justement et hier sur ce sujet
concernant la pornographie les adultes
surestime un petit peu le contact des
15-18 ans 26% des adolescents déjà vu
des films x 39 % des garçons contre 12 %
des filles alors que la moitié des
adultes pensent que c'est le cas pour
quasiment la totalité des jeunes alors
c'est vrai qu'il renvoie sur inquiétudes
les études sont assez variés killing sur
inquiétude ce n'est pas si étonnant
quand on touche à la sexualité on touche
quand même à quelque chose qui nous est
intime ce n'est pas des actes
complètement anodin six de ces actes là
que de fait nous sommes créés et donc
les adultes s'interroge c'est peut-être
aussi le reflet et nous l'avons constaté
qu'ils s'interrogeaient même sur leur
sexualité alors de fait il peut y avoir
ce phénomène je vais dire de projection
c'est pour ça que nous avons vraiment
voulu partir
des jeunes tels qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
non pas tant ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure des projections que nous pouvons
avoir de nos angoisses de nos peurs il
ya certainement un enjeu dans ces
assises est bien jaillir d'apaiser si la
bête de paisiblement de quoi parlons
nous vers quoi allons-nous neuf
adolescents sur 10 qui estime que le
sexe est moins important que le fait
d'aimer et d'être aimé en retour voilà
qui va sans doute vous faire plaisir
selon une enquête de l'institut ipsos
celle que je citais qui a été publié par
le parisien pour conclure l'église a un
rôle véritablement à jouer selon vous
dans la formation affective et sexuelle
des jeunes c'est la place de l'église
mais je crois que tout ce qui touche à
l'homme touche à l'église c'est à dire
que ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
humaniser permettre à chacun de
découvrir vraiment son humanité c'est le
projet de l'église et nous croyons de
fait que depuis deux mille ans ce
message qui a parfois pu être mal
compris parfois plus caricaturé mais ce
message est bien appuyé peu à peu
humaniser notre société je parle
j'évoquais tout à l'heure la tension
plus pauvres aux malades l'éducation
c'est ce que l'église a pu produire dans
ces deux mille ans c'est ce qu'elle
cherche à produire peut-être dans le
domaine de la sexualité et vous parler
aujourd'hui vous parler d'un message qui
a été mal compris le message a été mal
transmis aussi peut-être parfois en tout
cas les propos ont été quelquefois quand
même assez claire de la part de l'église
tout à fait alors est-ce qu'il est mal
musique solide et sur le port du
préservatif valeureux su bien sûr ce que
j'évoquais c'est qu'on tombe parfois
dans la caricature assez facilement et
on essaye avec une une petite expression
de ramasser un message qui de fait est
plus ample et justement ces assises ont
duré deux jours car ce n'est pas avec
des slogans en fait qu'on peut pouvoir
aborder cette question mais c'est au
contraire en prenant un peu de temps
mais chez de fait l'objectif de ces
aussi merci pierre mathieu du monde est
revenu sur ce plateau les assises sur
l'affectivité et la sexualité des jeunes
ce sera ce week end nous en parlerons
dans notre édition de lundi pour un
compte rendu merci à vous là demain 8
mai ce sera l'occasion également de
commémorer la victoire des alliés sur
l'allemagne nazie avant les cérémonies
la nation à honorer les anciens
combattants yvelinois ce matin le préfet
a remis les insignes de la légion
d'honneur à plusieurs d'entre eux
catherine vu la tomate il de capvern
ils marchent d'un pas décidé entouré de
sa famille assurément fier de la
médaille qui me porte depuis aujourd'hui
sur le revers de sa veste à 89 ans roger
delorme est un héros de la deuxième
guerre mondiale il vient de se voir
décoré de la légion d'honneur comme huit
autres anciens combattants son histoire
c'est celle d'un gamin qui vit dans les
vosges il a 17 ans et son destin bascule
j'avais à l'époque 17 ans je travaillais
en banque les allemands se montrent les
limites médical ville d'allemagne est en
bon état on veut avoir un âge et dînant
dans le camp journal et avait rien qui
me disent que les tirs ne maquille je
dormais nommé qui lie actuellement pas
connu mon père m'a dit
on a fait la guerre 14 18 il m'a dit 17
février prochain je vais pas il doit
servir la patrie la volonté de
jacqueline de paillard à l'époque les
femmes n'avaient pas le droit d'être
militaire etc comme ambulancière la
croix rouge qu'elle est intervenue dans
le conflit j'ai d'abord attendu d'avoir
21 ans pour que mon père accepte que je
bouge je suis parti dans la voit rouge
elle me suis trouvé à la croix rouge à
marseille
au moment du débarquement
jacqueline de paille à part ensuite sur
le front allemand pour la libération des
camps de concentration
l on découvre l'horreur est quelque
chose que je ne raconte jamais c'est
notre
nôtre
venu dans les tomes 2 2
et porter le premier que j'ai vu
j'ai éclaté
parce que le type il était squelettique
avec des gros sabots j'ai dit à une
fille et d'un côté moi je vis et il est
ma boule cela reste pourquoi il se
balade comme ça non ça c'est horrible
je me souviens toujours
il ya un type il avait avec les
trouveurs et en mai 81 pour moi ce dès
la taille de mes frais
alors je le voyais ce type là il pesait
30 kg
et je faisais avec mon pouce
le tour de son fémur
tellement il était maigre
9 légion d'honneur ont été remis ce
jeudi en préfecture un hommage de la
patrie à ce qu'il y a plus de 70 ans ont
servi à leur manière les notions de
fraternité et de liberté
mais après ces témoignages nous restons
à versailles mais du côté du château
après deux ans de travaux le bosquet du
théâtre d'auch va rouvrir au public et
dès le 12 mai les visiteurs vont pouvoir
découvrir une oeuvre contemporaine qui
trouvera qui trouve toute sa place au
milieu de la végétation
créer entre 1671 et 1677 par andré le
nôtre puis détruit en 1775 le bosquet du
théâtre d'auch et est en dormance depuis
de nombreuses années en 2009 le château
de versailles a décidé d'y créer un
jardin contemporain le paysagiste louis
benech et l'artiste jean michel othoniel
lauréat du concours international lancé
pour le réaménagement du bosquet ont
ainsi créé un projet audacieux dont les
travaux ont débuté en mai 2013 jean
michel othoniel a réalisé trois
sculptures fontaine monumentale appelé
joliment les belles danses ses oeuvres
en verre de murano s'inspire directement
des ballets donné par louis xiv pour moi
c'est vraiment une première puisque j'ai
jamais fait ça avant cette échelle et
surtout dans un lieu aussi prestigieux
donc assez assez
un moment et je pense inoubliable et
unique il ya aussi le côté festif et
joyeux puisque un coup les sculptures
prennent vie elles deviennent elles
deviennent vraiment des danses comme je
les ai rêvé c'est à dire que l'eau vient
amplifier le mouvement des perles on est
vraiment dans quelque chose de qui
raconte une histoire qui raconte aussi
l'histoire de versailles et l'histoire
de la danse du roi
cette réalisation sera présentée au
public à partir du 12 mai les deux
artistes ont conçu leurs créations à
partir du vestige du bosquet les effets
d'eau jouent avec le végétal une oeuvre
très contemporaine alors qu'on célèbre
cette année le tricentenaire de la mort
de louis xiv
et si vous aimez l'eau vous allez
apprécier ce que vous réserve l'île de
loisirs à trappes pour ce week end un
drôle d'engin baptisé aéro scouts sera
disponible gratuitement pour tv fils
c'est mikel et demi d'euros qui a suivi
la première initiation en avant première
sensations fortes garanties sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
jusqu'à ce dimanche des sessions d'aero
scouts sont programmés gratuitement ce
sport très en vogue chez les
milliardaires est désormais accessible
au plus grand nombre je vais mettre ma
combi et je viens vous présenter ce
sport unique
alors c'est un engin de sport propulsé
unique au monde qu'on a inventé donc on
a délocalisé le système de propulsion
sur la berge pour
propulser à l'aide d'un tuyau cette
petite machine et donc on au dessus tout
à fait
mais télévision
le but de la manoeuvre est temps de
passer de cette position aille position
debout en avançant le bassin
vers le guidon donc c'est très physique
non non ça demande juste une petite
question d'équilibré c'est un peu comme
le vélo quand on enlève les petites
couettes
rosicky
la fraude
la machine est capable de monter jusqu'à
10 mètres de hauteur ici on va limiter
les baptêmes à deux mètres de hauteur
s'est déjà largement suffisant de mètres
de hauteur c'est la hauteur les pieds
par rapport à l'eau donc votre regard
sera entre 3 à 4 mètres de hauteur de
ces lacs c'est vraiment impressionnant
tu fais
c'est vraiment un sport avec plein de
sensations c'était vraiment super sympa
en tout cas wilfried je te conseille
d'essayer
encore faut-il réussir à faire du vélo
sans les petites roulettes c'est la fin
du journal de ce jeudi 7 mai je vous
retrouve le lundi très bon week-end
prolongé tout de suite filets qu avec
florane parfait
il